more taco more Cody Moody
[Music]
over the last couple of months we've
reached some tremendous regeneration
milestones in June the Minister for
Greater Christchurch regeneration the
Honourable Megan woods held an official
ceremony for the handover of
regeneration land and des Council
ownership this is about land going back
to local ownership with communities
being fully in power of the future of
what happens in their community and I
think that is something that everybody
inc interbreed and celebrate in eighteen
point six million dollars in funding
over the next ten years has been
approved for the regeneration areas by
the council in the recent long term plan
this excellent it means there are the
next two or three years of projects are
now firmly set in concrete finishing the
wharf here and then moving on to the
playing playing field to end the BMX
track and the dog pack was up till now a
lot of it's been underground and not
very visible we're moving into the very
visible and and exciting bits now the
reconstruction of Courtney Drive is now
been completed and we really appreciate
the patience of nearby residents as this
work was carried out and we dealt with
the discovery of asbestos underneath the
road series
you've been in the area lately you would
have noticed the cranes working in the
area just behind me here today we're
going to get an update on progress in
the five-point marine fee so this is a
large project which involves the
installation of a new river wall the
driving of new piles and the complete
reconstruction of the stop being flowing
down the stop bang is for jennasmith to
come back in to install the tie backs
with a sheet pile wall which is pulling
on the tension for the new river wall
that's going in and then once that's
done you can will come back to reinstate
your stop bank and once that's done the
beautiful the terraces will come in and
start building the terraces steps the
terraces will be completed towards the
end of the year along with the
neighboring private development
installation of the floating pontoons
will require dredging of the river and
the resource consent process for that
work is well underway
new draft Kai for towns in the plan will
soon be out for public consultation this
document plans for the future of
quietboys
Town Center and the adjacent mixed-use
business areas make sure you take a look
at the plan and submit your feedback
when it's released in orders in the next
update we'll look at the soon to be
completed Road here in the Kuiper s
regeneration era which will be known as
pelvic drive and we'll also talk about
the master plan for this area which
includes things like the dog park and B
of each bar for more information about
the regeneration visit any council
service center or Waimakariri govt tnz
forge / regeneration
[Music]